you also I'm told are a pretty serious
video game fnatic is that right I mean
yeah I was a socially awkward kid so
I've been playing pokemon for like 19
years and that's actually helped me and
Vin Diesel became friends was I was on
Fast 7 and his sister found out that I
played World of Warcraft and so like
every night after filming we would like
to go over to his place and like sort of
computers on like other side of the room
like okay we're gonna go to this dungeon
Ringo do this that's what Vin Diesel
does in his off time - yeah so Vin
Diesel's in the corner and he's like
what character does he like to be um
yeah I think he had like a drawn I like
drew it or something like that I don't
think they can be true it's actually but
he had some kind of a druid and I
started off the night elf hunter like
most people do and he recommended that
via rogues and I got myself a blood elf
rogue and I actually really liked her a
lot
and I can like interact with people and
I don't know what you're talking I think
I reviewed that game for a video game
company I'm supposed to know this stuff
but I never do I never know what I'm
doing when I when I like talking to
people online I have no clue who I am
and just like you know be able to have
genuine interactions with people and
they're just nice just because and I
like it would you ever have the nerve to
ask someone you didn't know on LaHaye
what do you think of that Ronda Rousey
hahaha
no I wouldn't want to like taint the
experience yeah like you know now I have
to kill you with my hunter
you